What's actually happening
when a TCP connection opens?
Well what has to happen?
The two endpoints, the client and
server, have to get into agreement
that a connection exists.
Well what information has to be
exchanged in order for that to happen?
Before anything happens, the client
knows the server's IP address and
port number, but the server doesn't
know anything about the client.
So the client has to send
the server a message with,
among other things,
its IP address and port number,
saying that it wants to connect
to the server on its IP and port.
But TCP does more than that.
It also keeps track of the data
that each end point is sent.
And make sure that the other
end point has received it, and
make sure that the application sees that
data in order even if the underlying
network reorders the packets.
The way that it does this is by putting
a sequence number on each packet.
Each endpoint sends an acknowledgement
indicating when its
received a particular sequence number,
and if a packet goes missing the other
end point will notice there's no
acknowledgement and will re-transmit it.
Also, sequence numbers start
out at a random number so
they're very unlikely to get confused
between one connection and another.
So when the client sends
this first packet,
it has a sequence number on it like
number one two three four five.
And when the server sends back its first
response that has a different sequence
number, like nine, eight, seven, six,
it also contains an acknowledgement,
saying that the server has
received packets up to but
not including number one,
two, three, four, six.
And then subsequently each packet either
end sends has an acknowledgement or
ack for short.
That indicates one more than
the greatest sequence number.
For which it knows it doesn't
need anything re sent.
When the client sends the packet
containing its request.
The server acknowledges that request
even before it sends the response.
Then it will send the response and
the client will acknowledge each
packet that's used to send then.
For a realistically sized
file there will be many,
many more of these before we're done.
And since there will be many
more of these it's not just that
the server will be sending
a lot of data to the client.
The client will also be sending
an Ack back to the server for
each packet of that data.
And because that data is going to
be broken up into a lot of packets
each with its own sequence number on
it there are going to be a lot of
ack's flowing back.
Even though the client isn't
transmitting any application data back.
All those packets will
have data length zero.
They'll still be telling
the server how much data has been
successfully received.